[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning the salt helps
to dry out the humans even more and then
fresh ginger slice um nice and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
last little thin slices in there and
then keep that bunched up shank the
chili
[Music]
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now garlic nice now
add olive oil to your toasted cumin
seeds and then with a garlic ginger and
chili lovely it feels strange when you
talk about garlic for breakfast but the
time I spent in India everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary eats your bowl and set
aside next the pancake filling and olive
oil to a hot pan mustard seeds in now
they'll start dancing the minute they
hit the pan then finally slice an onion
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and I go to color and instant
change leftover potatoes just slice them
smell is incredible take us in now
spread the potatoes across the pan while
the potatoes stained I want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice
turmeric actually like a sponge season
those potatoes and really help to bring
out spice beautifully
[Music]
they're ready turn off the gas and let
me sit there and absorb all those
flavors back to the pancake batter
I've plain flour to your cooled garlic
chili ginger and cumin seeds touch salt
and pepper nothing worse than the bland
pancake one whole egg milk hold of jugs
one hand and whisper our secrets to get
that really nice smooth paste
but whisking that egg first and brings
it together
and then your milk in then put all the
milk in because any gonna get a lumpy
pancake mix if you put less milk in it
really helps it not going lumpy look at
that milk it
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix now just a little teaspoon of oil
that helps to bring a nice crispy edge
to the mixture now taste that's the
texture pan on the large of the pan the
better it helps to create a nice thin
even surface I want that mix gone all
the way around the pan before you put
the mixture into the pan make sure you
give your pancake mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot
turn down the gas a touch of olive oil
get that nice whisk with one hand pan to
the mix in one and a half ladles and
then roll it around which is really nice
and thin I want to see the ginger the
garlic that's what I'm looking for in
there now back onto the heat only starts
to remove from the bottom of the pan and
lifts itself up once it's cooked these
little bubbles confirm those just starts
and lifts off the pan a little shake
that releases it and then just shake it
to the end
and toss if you haven't got the content
of tossing then use a spatula and turn
it over now that's exactly what I want
that nice sort of crisp edge around the
side the color on the pancake is so
important
now roll it rounds and just let it slide
out usefully
and if now the exciting part filling
them take your potatoes you just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line and
then just very carefully roll that nice
tightly tuck it underneath there
put it back and roll
usually the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat but with a simple dipping sauce
they'll be a real treat
just mix chopped coriander with natural
yogurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit
that on the site and that for me is a
great brunch delicious spicy pancakes
amazing
[Music]
so cools down even more and then combine
it start mixing that in it's reading
three fingers one in front two behind
and this part of the knuckle